former president trump turning the
tables on the media as republicans ramp
up the pressure to release more
materials from the unprecedented fbi
raid on his home the press going into
full russia gate mode while trying to
disprove trump's claim that the bureau
seized his passports cbs anchor nora
o'donnell tweeting quote according to a
doj official the fbi is not in
possession of former president trump's
passports trump had accused the fbi of
stealing his three passports during the
search of his mar-a-lago home
the orange menace forced to correct the
record with his spokesman posting the
email that backs him up proving the
agency removed his travel documents from
mar-a-lago and would be returning them
the media is also ramping up their good
versus evil game
and i would say to our friends who are
watching us today
vote as if your life depends on it
because of life kevin mccarthy
threatened the possible next speaker of
the house the republicans win threatened
an attorney general and said you'd
better lay essentially you'd better lay
off trump or else there's going to be
violence are we going to survive this
i don't know the hopeful part of this is
that america does have resilience and we
do get over moments like this
and remember how this raid was urgently
needed to protect national security
turns out attorney general merrick
garland sat on his butt and waited weeks
to approve the search warrant
and we still don't know what the
underlying evidence that was used to
justify agents going through melania's
wardrobe right now the doj recommends to
keep that sealed
but a judge set a thursday hearing to
determine whether the public gets to see
it or not
senator lindsey graham says the american
public needs transparency now
we need the affidavit show you cards
merrick garland can't have it both ways
he can't give us the inventory the
warrant without telling us why it was
necessary without the affidavit
we're flying blind in the dark and the
american people are going through too
much pain too much heartache on this
endless effort to destroy donald trump
judge welcome back thank you you were
missed
really yes
thank you i missed you too oh you and
you and you you i didn't miss because
you weren't here when
let's remember who's going to be
conducting this hearing on thursday it's
the same judge who signed uh the warrant
right okay so
you've got this judge who signed a
warrant that apparently was messed up
from the get-go and i'll tell you why
if it were a search warrant and they
made a decision to go beyond a a
subpoena with a court order there had to
be some exigent circumstance there had
to be some emergency then we find out
that merrick garland waited weeks before
he actually made a final decision on
that and then we find out that even
before then in june the president was
cooperating with the uh uh the narrative
people the national archives people who
sent them a thank you note for
cooperating so with this hearing the
judge has to decide look we've got we've
got the american public has an interest
in this but the department of justice is
saying no we don't want you to release
this affidavit the basis for the warrant
because we think it will compromise
whatever investigation we're doing that
it will cause harm to certain people if
it's being released and that it doesn't
serve a public interest and that there
is sensitive information and they'll get
a road map to where we're going
but on the other hand in my 30 years in
law enforcement i have never heard of a
of a defendant and remember this is a
criminal warrant based on a statute that
is not a criminal statute the national
archives record and so what he's saying
the president of the united the
ex-former president is saying
release it i don't care what it says i'm
not worried about what it says so this
judge is in a box the judge has to say
hey wait a minute when we've got the
defendant himself who's not a party the
uh the supposed wannabe defendant he's
not even a party he's saying let it all
out you know the judge then has to
decide
was it a wholesale fishing expedition
now he knows america's tuned into this
they took passports the media based on
nora o'donnell saying oh they didn't
take it you know it's like we gotta
warrant a legitimate warrant from the
fisa court after we lied after
christopher steele did a dossier that
hillary clinton paid for but no worries
justice is still good with the fbi
and if you believe that then you got a
problem but in the end this judge i
think is going to make a decision that
it's got to be released that they will
only redact certain parts of it
and uh i think that i think there's egg
on the face of merrick garland the
department of justice and the fbi yeah
enough to make it 10 egg omelette dana
you know i didn't realize we're gonna
have michael beschloss and that's how do
you say his name that's right all right
whatever his name is this is the same
guy that tweeted about uh tweeted the
rosenbergs yeah uh executed like
they sold uh they sold uh
sold secrets to moscow and they were
executed the inference being that trump
would be executed too who how what right
does he have a lot of the historians
have been concerned for the last is it
seven years now about norms and
institutions and the protection of the
constitution etc and i was just thinking
about um
this when you were talking judge
the defendant is not even really a
defendant yet no right no so
and we still believe in innocent until
proven guilty
and that's in the constitution and we
still believe that the burden is on the
prosecution so at this point i don't
understand how he could also say the
norms of the country are at risk but
also tweet something that basically says
donald trump is guilty of selling
secrets to the russians
given all of those things that doesn't
make sense and i do wish that
it's
with on the media side of things i know
you want to be first but it's more
important to be right and the whole
passport thing just stirred the pot even
further to make people less
convinced that this is on the upper end
yeah same with the nuke stuff it's like
people just it it just sounds so much
like russian collusion joey and the
other thing too i have we hear about why
do they go into melania's closet there
could be a really simple answer to that
that maybe that's where the safe was why
don't they say that or why aren't they
saying that i think i wouldn't
acknowledge that either if i were them
because it's it's way too low-hanging
fruit it's fun i mean you see means of
merit garland and you know elaborate
evening gowns now yes you know look at
where we are as a country right now
because of of what happened at
mar-a-lago half the country or at least
the politically active charged right
half thinks president trump is being
persecuted unfairly once again and the
other half of the country
would just assume have president trump
uh i guess executed for treason even
those are polar opposites there's a lot
of in between but
why would the fbi why would the body
administration take steps to put us in
this position today
it's not to say that trump deserves
special treatment i understand the
argument that those documents probably
belong to the united states government
and needed to find their way back there
it sounds like they're negotiating on on
how to keep those things safe seems like
they were in a really good agreement a
really good place and then they said
because of an fbi source and
surveillance they had reason to believe
that those documents weren't as secure
as they wanted them to be and that was
the precipice of this raid that's what
caused it and you take a step back say
trump doesn't deserve special treatment
but the american people don't deserve to
be thrown into another polarizing
situation where we sit around and have
arguments where we could be having
discussions where we sit around and say
oh my god the government's going after
trump yet again or we sit around and say
oh trump's trying to sell our nuclear
secrets to the soviets i don't believe
either one of those are wholesale true
but you got a lot of reason for people
to sit around and make those arguments
now because of this in my opinion
careless action
you know richard what happens when you
have a poorly made burrito it falls
apart when you're driving and i think
that's what's happening here that this
narrative is falling apart as the media
drives it and they don't know what to do
what are your thoughts besides agreeing
wholeheartedly with me well i won't do
that and i don't eat burritos while i'm
driving um but i have this close circuit
camera footage of you doing that do
yes really you got to consult my lawyers
before you do that
um a couple things here listen i think
there's a lot of media speculation uh
on all sides right both on the right and
the left people are trying to speculate
what they were were we in melania's
closet were we not melania's closet
everybody trying to speculate what these
11 doc classified or confidential
documents that were raided from the well
that were taken from mar-a-lago i think
we have to wait to see that we'll find
out tomorrow when this we'll find on the
18th when this judge has this hearing i
think we should release the affidavit
normally judges don't do that because
you don't want to tarnish the reputation
of the defendant but because he wants it
released let's release and let's get to
the bottom of it but with that being
said i think there's far too much
speculation and i i also think that you
know when people like oh this is a
faulty warrant think about the levels of
clearance that this warren had to go
through not only was it signed off by
christopher wray who was appointed by
donald trump to be the head of the fbi
but it was also appointed by it was also
signed off by mayor garland and remember
he has decades on the federal bench and
progressives have knocked merrick
garland for being too slow too judicious
but that's what judges do they're
judicious and so i think he's very
judicious and on top of that it went to
a federal judge and then the federal
judge said based on this information
based on this evidence our own jackie
heinrich reported that it's very likely
that the person that part of this
evidence is somebody from his security
detail his secret service details sworn
officers of the court saw classified
documents they have a mandatory ability
they have a mandatory rule to report and
they reported that we saw those
documents
are they not officers of the court could
you imagine putting your life in the
hands of someone who wants to write you
out over that like yeah
garland is so judicious uh how come he
called parents domestic terrorists and
sick the fbi on them i have a little
trouble with that being judicious all
right me too
by the way melania's closet sounds like
a sitcom on hallmark
sounds like a great place to shop yeah
that is true
all right hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now